okay so we have gone from upgrading to
ascending what comes after that
catapulting
[Applause]
[Music]
ha that was a stupid joke ok but before
we can get into it I need to say that
this particular episode is sponsored by
the radio versus the Martians podcast
which you should definitely check out
and listen to the host Mike Gillis and
Casey Doran they cover anything geeky
from ghostbusters to vigilante sub-genre
of films to Planet of the Apes to Batman
you name it they will talk about it it's
the McLaughlin group for nerds and they
are always worth your time fun funny
insightful check them out at Radio
versus the Martians calm or wherever you
get your podcasts so the Ascension of
the Cyberman the first part of a
two-part finale for series 12 of Doctor
Who and it's hard for me to have an
opinion on it things that are very
clearly the first part of two parters
that can often be the case because more
often than not it is going to be nearly
entirely dependent on the second half as
to whether or not it is going to
completely work there are exceptions
there are some first halves that are
great in and of themselves world enough
in time springs to mind I also consider
the impossible planets stellar on its
own even if you don't get the concluding
half but most two parters you know you
think back to army of ghosts or honestly
even a sound of drums you don't quite
feel like you've gotten the whole thing
you kind of have to reserve judgment
until you see the second half and I kind
of feel like that's the case here but I
need to review it in some fashion so
here we go I guess I think this did a
very good job of solidifying the threat
of the Cybermen and indefinitely I would
say this is the most successful new who
has been in making them feel like a
properly large-scale plan
Herry galactic size threat I'd say there
was a threat to be felt in world enough
in time but that was the what felt
threatening was the creeping factor and
you know the idea of the conversion
itself not so much the idea of they're
gonna you know go out and destroy all of
humanity they've tried to sell that with
the Cybermen at various points across
the show and I've never really bought it
a like and that's not to say that I
haven't enjoyed the Cybermen but you
know they they don't feel like as big a
threat as the show usually treats them
as and in some cases likes a nightmare
and silver they they try so hard to sell
the threat of these things but for
various reasons that just doesn't click
it clicks here this feels threatening
their presence especially Ishod you know
the lone Cyberman he's he is
intimidating a second I really we still
don't know his full deal but him saying
I
I basically volunteered that kind of
fits with what I can bend my head cannon
from the previous episode this idea of
like there's something off about him
even when he was a human being there was
something off about this guy that is
contributing to the way that he is
behaving as a Cyberman because as gets
pointed out in this episode normally you
break the emotional inhibitor and they
can feel then you know they kind of lose
it if not explode but here he's clearly
feeling he's angry he's frustrated he
has a sense of victory and triumph but
he's not losing his mind so on some
level he is cool with what's happened to
him and what he's become and that to me
is kind of fascinating and the little
bit more we see of him here really
reasserts that and so I'm I'm digging
that quite a bit there was a genuine
sense of fear I had for the Companions
like when when Yasin Graham got on that
ship
and Orion wasn't with them I did find
myself thinking oh god if they've split
up the companions that opens up the
possibility that somebody could die
because I don't think you sure would
ever kill all three companions at and at
a swipe that's not gonna happen
but you separate them suddenly Ryan
becomes a viable death and you know you
see the situation that Graeme has and
the people that they escaped with rning
you think I could see one of them not
making it out of this - so there's a
really good sense of tension in here the
whole thing with the Irish cop who's
found as a baby raised becomes a local
you know Guardsman I think they say it's
something or something like that gets
shot and falls off a cliff somehow
survives lives - retirement and then
unaged like his the guy who hi brought
him onto the onto the police force and
his adopted dad on aged take him to the
back room to resect him and wipe his
mind and go again and I don't know
what's going on with that I don't know I
don't even know if I have a theory on
that I mean aside from like there are
some things that I have read and I try
and avoid fan theory or potential leaks
but there was something someone brought
to my attention that I had read and my
brain keeps going to that cuz I could
see how this would fit into that thing
and I'm not gonna say what it was I
don't mean to beat easy like that but
like I hate it
I hate it so much and I don't want to
taint anyone else's experience by them
dreading that this is what's gonna
happen but I am a little bit nervous
because while I'm not gonna say that
this definitely points to oh they are
gonna do that thing that I read about I
could see how this could fit in to that
so I I part of me wishes that I could
have seen something that would have much
more felt like oh well there's no way
this fits into that stupid potential
leaked plot thing that I read good
because that was dumb so I'm gone and
even setting all that aside I am gonna
be going into the final episode very
nervous because of how much is riding on
it because you know with the lone
Cyberman we have so this episode the one
immediately preceding to some degree
fugitive of the Judoon and now the
master is tied in with that so you can
put the spy fall two-parter as well and
you can say that all of the all of those
to varying degrees are really kind of
dependent on the last episode of
sticking the landing because if the last
episode blows it then those episodes
maybe not completely but to some degree
are going to be made less and those were
all good episodes so I'm I'm nervous
only because of how much is riding on it
and we haven't even brought back roof
yet it's to the point and they're
juggling so much now especially with
this introduction of whatever the heck
was going on with that with that Irish
cop guy that I don't know if there's
space to sort Routh out and I'm
wondering if that is something that is
going to get picked up again next series
because it was also mentioned by Jim
know that Jack doesn't appear again this
series he just had the one initial
appearance that we saw which again we
kind of in to indicate that some of
these plans are planning to roll
over to the next series which is another
thing that makes me nervous
the idea of stretching out the story
over more than one series doctor who
hasn't really done that too much it did
it a little bit I guess with how the
cracks in time led into the silence
which didn't really get properly wrapped
up until time of the doctor but that
didn't work so I don't like that my main
go-to comparison for basically a
multi-season arc and it was something
that didn't work I am happy to see the
master backed I I like I like this
iteration of the master I have a lot of
fun with him so I like having him back I
would be curious what I see Jodie
Whittaker is bringing a lot of strength
to the doctor in this episode and I saw
some of this previous episode as well
and that's really nice to see she she
almost felt too friendly and
accommodating in series 11 there wasn't
always a proper sense of urgency about
her but in definitely getting that here
and you're getting you know the weight
of her passing house with the Cyberman
particularly I think bill and the and
what happened to her
in addition to that they're evoking a
lot of different stuff with the Cybermen
you know they are Avoca
the Cybermen they are revoking basically
earth shock by the head shape for the
the warrior class or whatever it is and
the fact that they're all you know lined
up in these boxes effectively like that
was very earth shock that all reveal so
that was cool I like given that Chibnall
has a tendency at least in Doctor Who to
you know so far this series especially
be you know just picking up bits and
pieces of what's been done before and
just kind of remix in it
if that's how she's going to approach
this which I'm enjoying certainly this
series and enjoying it more than his
attempt to like do nothing but new stuff
with series 11 I'm glad that he is remix
elements from classic and not just
earlier new whoo I like that he's
reaching back farther for that for first
smaller points of reference not
necessarily four and now we bring back
this creature like know to drop names
like the Guardians that we got in can
you hear me and now you know sort of
this stuff reminiscent of earth shock
and that's that is cool and I do enjoy
that quite a bit the supporting cast was
fine for the most part some of them
seemed a little forced a little clunky
but none of them like were on screen and
like demanded the screen time enough
that that bothered me too much and like
I said the doctor was really good in
this I do like the lone Cyberman
I think he's super effective as a
villain I really dig him the flying
Cyberman heads were a little goofy and
it's okay for Doctor Who to get a little
goofy sometimes but this is is a bit of
a more serious feel to it so I'm not
sure that this was the episode to pull
that specifically but like that's a tiny
moment and as nervous as I am going to
the finale this was a solid piece of
setup so we'll see what happens
ascension of the Cybermen what do you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something on down in the
comments and let's talk about it usual
stuff as well support me on patreon I
hit 250 supporters on there which is
amazing and seriously any amount helps
even it's all our month
honestly it adds up and it allows me to
keep this going and make it bigger and
make it better
so thank you for that and you of course
the usual stuff like subscribe share
this video around but you also don't
have to do any of it because end of the
day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]